hello there I'm Gavin I'm done with the
slow mo guys and that I was watching
videos on the internet and I came across
a bloke called grant Thompson who made a
match rocket here's one I made earlier
mine looks rubbish compared to his but
see if it works
didn't have any slow-mo in his video so
we're going to set off a few match
Rockets go in slow-mo apparently they've
got like 40 feet yo here's can go 40
feet I'm thinking about 4 feet 4 feet VA
probably about alright let's see how it
looks sweet that's good how these flat
boys work then Daniel to get the right
trajectory basically there's a match
head in the top there and you're going
to heat that up with a flame of some
sort and then when it reached a certain
temperature through the foil it's going
to combust causing an expansion of gas
within a sort of sealed full chamber
which has been plugged up by this nail
and then that's going to cause it to
fire off into the distance they are not
sponsored by Famous Amos yeah they are
delicious cookies no add one she gonna
film this on the old fellow flex 2 and a
thousand frames maybe we should hit you
in the face of it
Yeah right t-minus some seconds one way
I was good distance
I was good that huh I got 20 feet it's
like a miniature actual rocket it's not
the plane blaster that's working that's
an enthusiasm oh that's cool
they're lovely actually stabilizers cool
now I love the glow trails smoke it's so
satisfying so it's a good sound as I
look he's heading right for the house oh
you can see like it changing direct
looki course corrections okay here's the
facial impact I'm going to say ten
points for the nose yeah and five points
for anything else that sounds good on
your head three two one Oh
let me know oh good haha that's great
and look at her straight viable was even
spinning up in here oh did I see that
you see this man Jesus that's great
mechanical better we saw a map well I
thought that video worked tremendously
straighten right yeah it was Richard
directly mister just satisfying clunk
when the other gun well I was actually
debating goggles all that has really
gonna go to I yeah yeah yeah it's more
exact you reacted to is if it actually
hit my uh I've got goals them thanks to
grant Thompson for the inspiration for
that video it's pretty cool inspiration
you can actually watch a video on how to
make these little match rockets the link
is in the description feel free to
follow us on the twits buy a shirt if
you want if Dan sees you wearing a shirt
that is a slow mo guys shirt he will buy
you a drink
why do is do this sinners contract and
order a really expensive one order like
a martini or so cocktails and cocktails
yeah mojito also subscribe to the
channel because a bunch of slow-mo on it
there's over 100 videos these days so
sweet really offer of these days
you
good good concentration face there is it
good yeah I'm doing get this is my
concentration face right yeah
nice good work but no no it's good